I've been following the 2020 Democratic
primary campaign of Andrew yang with
great interest for a while now and I've
had him on the show a couple of times
and my attention yesterday was called to
an interview that Andrew yang did on the
Fox Business channel with this fat cat
Stuart Varney and I call him that
because when you see this guy he is just
a caricature of the typical rich dude
fat cat who can't be bothered to think
about how it is that someone making
twenty seven thousand dollars a year is
going to live day-to-day and last year
he brought Andrew yang on and it was
just amazing because Andrew yang utterly
crushed Stuart Varney Varney started to
play semantic games about universal
basic income which is a big issue for
Andrew and about socialism and then when
it became clear that Andrew yang wasn't
going to be pushed around that Andrew
yang he really knows what he's talking
about
Stuart Varney just starts smirking and
talking about Oh handouts and free stuff
let's take a look at this first part of
the interview and you will see very
quickly that Andrew yang is in complete
control and Stuart Varney has no idea
what to do
other than to just start repeating
phrases that are red meat to the Fox
News audience we are the owners and
stakeholders of the society the exact
way that the owners and stakeholders of
a company receive a dividend every
quarter total socialism socialism and
you're smart enough to know this
socialism is when and thank you know is
when a country nationalizes the means of
production this is any fault this is the
Old Market and throw consumer Pro market
yes very much so consumer markets eat
too much water you just have to put your
hand out
that's not a market well no American
watching this right now is going to quit
their job on $1,000 a month that is not
enough to do more than to survive
marginally in most any situation what
they're going to do is I'm going to take
that money they're going to start new
businesses they're going to go back to
school they're going to frequent their
Main Street economy and we're all going
to be better off for it okay so you can
see that Stuart Varney has no idea how
to respond to this because Andrew yang
is very able and incapable of explaining
that this isn't socialism also who is
going to just say I am fine living on
thousand dollars a year and have no
interest in working at all most people
are not going to do that
so we're gonna continue and we're gonna
back it up a few seconds just so you can
really make sure you hear Stuart Varney
'he's next comment where we're going to
pick it up he does what is the
equivalent of the white flag when you
run out of arguments you strawman your
opponent with utopian nonsense and what
I mean by that is you're gonna hear
Stuart Varney go paradise right it'll
just be paradise if we're able to do
what you're suggesting that's what you
do when you've lost the argument
Andrew yang isn't saying 10,000 a year
of ubi is paradise he's recognizing our
problems are way bigger than just giving
everybody 10,000 bucks and he explains
that but when you see Stuart Varney say
paradise right it's because he has no
good explanation as to why this isn't a
good idea they're going to frequent
their Main Street economy and we're all
going to be better off for it paradise
right well we have to start thinking
bigger about what direction we want to
move in as a society because the truth
is I was just out in Silicon Valley last
month we are going through the greatest
technological and economic shift in
human history and we need to make much
bigger moves towards an economy that's
sustainable over the long term for all
Americans what you have to understand
and I think a lot of Fox News viewers
don't when they watch this is that
Stuart Varney presents no arguments
Andrew yang proposes a policy 10,000 a
year ubi and Stuart Varney simply says
socialism Andrew yang explains no it's
not actually socialism and Stuart Varney
says paradise right and Andrew yang says
no I'm also not saying it's paradise
what I'm saying is most people want to
make more than 10 grand a year 10 grand
a year isn't paradise we can afford it
here's how it would be good
calling Andrew yang a socialist also is
super interesting because it just
doesn't work Andrew yang is no more
socialist than Donald Trump is a
socialist these are capitalist
businesspeople the main difference is
Yang understands economics and Yang's
businesses haven't declared bankruptcy
to the best of my knowledge so I really
like here Pat what Andrew yang is doing
and what's refreshing to me about him is
he doesn't do talking point games he
just talks like a normal person which is
one of the things that
was praised for in 2016 when we
interviewed him he said when I asked him
okay well what's the plan here for
making progress and for getting into the
debates he didn't give the sort of vague
grandiose talking points he said listen
the next stage is the the Iowa caucuses
or the first test 50,000 votes would get
me enough to get momentum into the
second primary that's what I'm trying to
get and I do find that refreshing about
him yeah Andrew yang is having an open
and honest conversation from a place of
good faith and you can't say the same
thing about Stuart Varney I can kind of
understand Varney's ignorance on this
matter because you know universal basic
income is only starting to seep into the
mainstream in part because of Andrew
yang but what I can't excuse is his just
complete dismissal of it you have to be
able to take in new arguments take in
new ideas and think about them don't
just dismiss them as pie in the sky's
rainbows and butterflies like he did
there yeah well it's Fox Business so
that's simply not going to happen really
nice job by Andrea and glad that that
that that was put in front of me over
the weekend and I look forward to seeing
what Andrew yang does next okay there's
this Dutch historian named Rutger
Bregman who sort of went viral when he
went to Davos a few weeks ago and said
hey the problem is tax avoidance none of
you people here are talking about it
corporations represented at Davos don't
want to talk about it rich people who
are speaking at Davos don't want to talk
about it and tax avoidance and tax rates
are what we need to be talking about a
very interesting clip that he
participated in from Davos this got
Tucker Carlson from Fox News interested
in Rutger Bregman and in fact Rutger
Bregman recorded an interview on Tucker
Carlson's program last week but the
interview was never aired we now have
leaked video from the control room of
this interview again the interview never
aired on Fox News Rutger Bregman
absolutely destroys Tucker Carlson
completely embarrasses and triggers him
to the point where Tucker Carlson starts
hurling expletives insults and obscenity
at Rutger Bregman and this ran
completely counter to the character that
Tucker Carlson is known for and wants to
portray which is that of being
completely in control at all times being
a master debater all of that different
stuff it went south
Tucker clearly didn't know how to handle
the obvious truths that Bregman was
confronting him with I'm not gonna play
all of it but let's check out a few
pieces of this interview excuse me of
this interview here is where Bregman
starts going in on Fox News during his
interview with Tucker Carlson no one's
saying that I devote just as no one
saying it on Fox News right and I think
the explanation for that is quite simple
is that most of the people in Davos but
also here on this channel have been
bought by the billionaire class you know
you're not meant to say these things so
I just went there and I thought you know
what I'm just gonna say it just as I'm
saying it right here on this channel for
years I've been against right even
though the vast majority of Americans is
in favor of it okay so you can already
see that Tucker Carlson sort of unsure
about how to handle what's going on here
so he starts to try to divert he says I
don't know how much Fox you've watched
but Bregman goes back to this main point
time and time again and in this next
clip you'll notice Tucker starting to
get more and more annoyed with them no I
mean it doesn't work that directly but I
mean you've been part of the Cato
Institute right you're you've been a
senior fellow there for years you've
been you've been taking their dirty
money they're funded by coke
billionaires you know well it works by
you taking their dirty money it's as
easy as that I mean you are a
millionaire funded by billionaires
that's what you are and I'm glad you now
finally Jim the bent leg and you know of
people like Bernie Sanders and a
see but you're not you're not part of
the solution mr. and mr. Colson you're
part of the problem actually so later on
Tucker continues to get more and more
annoyed tells Bregman you haven't even
watched Fox News because it's not on in
Europe and of course Bregman just points
out that the internet exists it's true
right
it's true right that all the all the
anchors all the anchors on Fox they're
all millionaires how is this possible
well it's very easy you're just still
talking about certain things it doesn't
play where you are well have you heard
of the internet I can watch the things
whatever I want I have actually so the
argument becomes over whether Rutger
Bregman is even able to watch fox news
from europe and then here's the sort of
last piece of this where Tucker just
completely loses it you're all like oh
I'm against a globalist the lead blah
blah blah it's not very convincing to be
honest absolutely great stuff never
aired only when it leaked did Tucker
Carlson have to give some kind of an
explanation which he did last night on
Fox News he put out a video claiming to
assert why they didn't air it as if we
needed an explanation here's what Tucker
claims are the reasons this never got
broadcast he was in Europe at the time
so we taped the segment in case we need
to fix the delay in the Edit booth we do
that a lot things went fine for the
first few minutes and then Bregman
launched into an attack on Fox News it's
not clear that Bregman has ever seen Fox
but he wanted to make his point fine but
then he claimed that my corporate
masters tell me what to say on this show
and that was too much whatever my faults
are those of this channel nobody in
management has ever told us what
positions to take on the air never not
one time we have total freedom here and
we're grateful for that I've hosted
shows on both the other cable channel so
I know firsthand how rare that freedom
is this show thanks to Fox we get to say
exactly what we think is true for better
or worse but there was no convincing
Rutger Bregman of that he knew what he
knew so I did what I try hard never to
do on this show and I was rude I called
him a [ __ ] and then I modified that
word with a vulgar vulgar anglo-saxon
term that is also intelligible in Dutch
my defense I would say that that was
entirely accurate but you're not allowed
to use that word on television so once
I'd said it out loud there was no airing
this segment these explanations make
absolutely no sense
so first Tucker says well Bregman was
rude and he said things that weren't
true
so we cancelled the segment well wrong
people being rude to Tucker is sort of
like how his show gets ratings and
people being rude to each other and
yelling and and making claims like this
it makes for great TV normally as long
as Carlson feels like he's still in
control and he would just call the guy
out as rude if he hadn't lost control of
the segment then he says well I swore on
camera and that makes the segment not
usable well you could have removed that
one piece like you said you weren't
doing it live so that you would have the
opportunity to edit it if possible
you also could just bleep the word the
way that we did in the version that we
aired so the idea that the entire
segment was no longer usable because he
dropped an f-bomb is also not believable
and then he says we didn't air it
because Bregman said things that weren't
true like for example that my bosses
tell me what to say which is again not a
reason not to air the segment just tell
him why he's wrong people have gone on
the tucker carlson program before and
asserted things tucker doesn't believe
to be true
he doesn't cancel the segment when that
happens so this is just not how it works
and there's a couple really important
things I want to mention here number one
there are some leftists who including my
friend Jen Kyogre with peace and love
who who tweeted that he thinks that
Tucker should be praised for actually
talking about tax avoidance I don't
agree that Tucker deserves praise for
this segment he didn't bring Rutger
Bregman on to actually have a discussion
about race
tax rates and stopping tax avoidance he
brought Rutger Bregman on to criticize
Jeff Bezos and specific left associated
billionaires and the so-called elites
who go to Davos and quote limousine
liberals and to make this a partisan
attack on supposedly hypocritical
leftists who pay low taxes and have a
bunch of money but call for high taxes
but don't actually pay for them this was
not a good-faith effort to actually
expose the problems with the tax code
across the world and particularly in the
United States that allow people like
Tucker to pay really low rates if he had
done it in good faith it would have been
one thing but he didn't and then lastly
the accusation that Rutger Bregman
levies on Tucker as a millionaire
controlled by billionaires on fox news
that's actually not unique to fox news
if you understand how corporate media
works you could make that argument about
most of the people on CNN you could make
that argument about most of the people
on MSNBC although yes on MSNBC because
of their editorial perspective you do
see more people talking about why
economically it would be better to have
higher taxes you're still dealing with
corporate structures where it's
billionaires controlling millionaires
and even if they don't tell them what to
say this is the old RT defense no one
from Russia tells me what to say they
don't tell me to say pro-russia stuff
you are hired because they know what
you're going to say and what you're
going to say is useful to them that's
not actually how it works so overall we
know why it didn't get aired because
Tucker got embarrassed it wasn't a
good-faith attempt to talk about
taxation and good for Rutger Bregman
although I agree he was doing a lot of
talking over talking over Tucker and
interrupting him and if there's any
criticism it would be that he shouldn't
have done that because it makes you sort
of seem overtly adversarial but I
understand why he did it and he did a
really really good job let me know what
you think about this segment I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show okay we've
got to talk about a problem that we're
experiencing at the David Pakman show
we have had over the years we've had our
share of struggles on the show
when it comes to finances YouTube D
monetization as well as the Amazon
revenue fiasco a couple years ago and
all sorts of different stuff but one
area where we have been killing it over
the last six months is audience growth
we've had nice steady growth for ten
years on the show but the last six
months have just been a period of
massive massive growth and I told you
that in January we had almost 500 new
paid members in February were already
off to a great start with a couple of
hundred new members already the YouTube
channel is growing the subreddit is
growing Facebook Twitter it's all going
very very well in terms of audience but
the downside of this is that we seem to
have gone over sort of some threshold
where there has been a monstrous influx
of nonsense in terms of trolls bots and
chills that a lot of our viewers and
listeners are getting annoyed by and
that's exactly the point of it that's
the point of this trolling and I want to
ask you in the audience today what do
you want us to do about it if anything
and I'll present some options in a
second how how do you want us to handle
this problem on Twitter we are being
overrun by spammy accounts with zero
followers who only reply to me and to
the show account they exist only to show
up in the replies to stuff that we post
personally I mute them as quickly as I
can
but they want to wreak havoc they want
to sow discord that's the strategy they
want to divide our audience as much as
possible and get in the way of sensible
discussion on YouTube we now have that
the numbers are just stunning we now
have at any given time more than 100,000
comments automatically stuck in the spam
filter we're putting this up on the
screen for people to look at
historically there were between 10 and
20,000 comments at any given time in the
YouTube spam filter we now have as of
when I took the screenshot 111,000 56
comments in the spam filter this is
YouTube's automated spam filter okay
it's not great like tons tons of non
spam
we'll be accidentally flagged tons of
actual spam will get through and just be
posted but historically there's only
about 10 to 20% of this number of
comments stuck in the spam filter a lot
of comments with triple parentheses
around my name right that anti-semitic
thing often times picking fights within
the left comments like I hate Trump as
much as the next guy but type of stuff
and then you also have the straight-up
bot comments like we will see 200
comments come in that are identical from
the same user on 200 different videos in
a five minute period even the most
tech-savvy individual is not doing that
right these are automated posting
systems lately people have been seizing
on issues where some of my audience
disagrees with me to foment this
division and of course there are plenty
of good faith people I want to be really
clear I'm not saying everybody who
disagrees with me about Venezuela is a
bot or a troll I'm not saying everyone
who disagrees with me about Israel is a
bot or a troll but what I am pointing
out is that there are a lot of accounts
on Twitter YouTube and in particular on
reddit that are being created simply to
make one post for example on our
subreddit and over the weekend I was
looking at some of these and it is
really really bad on Facebook it's
brutal what's going on there people
commenting on our page and tagging us in
all sorts of trolling and nonsense posts
so what I am asking for your advice on
here today is what do you want us to do
about this because one approach and
historically the approach has been we do
nothing right on YouTube we don't ban
block or delete comments if community
members flagged comments YouTube might
remove them but we don't get involved
because with thousands of comments a day
it's really difficult to do that the
problem is that they win if we do that
pat in that they make it impossible for
people who want to talk in good faith
about the content of the show to have
conversations and I get emails every day
from people saying David I'm off your
subreddit because
just troll central it's just people who
are making it impossible to actually
have conversation so then the opposite
approach would be we now have to get
involved get way more moderators and
start picking what is over the line
beyond just personal attacks which has
historically been been sort of the rule
and we start removing content but then
they also win with that Pat because then
we are censoring so I genuinely don't
know what to do about this problem yeah
and I'm going to do my part and start
deleting some of my 6000 accounts on
various social media platforms that are
programmed to leave pro pat propaganda
but I can't be the only one here other
people have to chip in too yeah Pat sock
puppet accounts are going to be removed
by tomorrow morning don't worry about
that so listen this is a big problem and
they sort of win either way because they
either win by making some of these
platforms unusable and really
unpalatable to our core audience or they
win by forcing us to have to make
decisions about what is and isn't going
to be allowed and then it becomes all
about a censoring and doing that type of
thing so I don't know what to do I want
to hear from you about how we should
handle this now let's get to what's
going on on Fox News in response to the
declaration of this national emergency
around the u.s. border wall and
immigration by Donald Trump even on Fox
News they can't avoid having some voices
of reason admit that this is all
completely bogus I'm not going to rehash
the entire case for you but as you know
if you watched the first segment in
today's show Trump said he didn't have
to do it illegal border crossings are
down there simply is no crisis period
multiple Fox hosts have admitted on live
television that this is all a joke let's
start with Shep Smith who's getting just
crushed by the Fox News audience who's
calling for his head Shep just pointing
out that the absurd path of this entire
thing is completely laughable then it
was one point seven offer from the
Democrats and then it was one point
three and then somehow you're supposed
to try to push that together and roll it
and spin it and churn it out and twist
it and turn it into something too
vaguely resembling a win and it really
didn't matter if you you put it on that
machine down there on the Jersey Shore
and pulled it like taffy and twisted it
and packaged it and put a bow on it and
dipped it in chocolate it's not a win
it's just that's not what a win like
that it walks like a loss and quacks
like a loss you know it's just a loss
and it was a loss and the president said
I don't want a loss
he's like national emergency so here we
go that's Shepard Smith and then Chris
Wallace saying what's just obvious that
this just isn't a real national
emergency sometimes the simplest
language is enough there's no emergency
and you're going to see in this next
clip Chris Wallace just visibly
struggling with how do you explain this
and he comes up with the obvious truth
which is the the primary difference
between this national emergency and all
of the others that are still active is
that all of those others are actually
defensible as emergencies are 30 or 31
emergencies that are currently that have
been enacted by earlier presidents that
are still active but they are on very
different matters they're unreal
national emergencies are things like
freezing the funding that the assets in
this country of terrorists it's a very
different thing when you've had a debate
for years as we have over funding a wall
and Congress has decided not to give
that funding to the president for him
then to say well I'm going to declare a
national emergency and take that funding
anyway I don't think there's ever been a
declaration of a national emergency like
that work yeah so I like Shep Smith and
Chris Wallace sort of shaking up the
echo-chamber of the fox news audience
but I do wonder whether it's a sort of
double edged sword because it allows Fox
News to say hey we are fair and balanced
we have a diversity of opinions we have
everybody and then we have Shep Smith
and every once in a while chris wallace
and it makes them it provides them cover
for saying there's a diversity of
opinion there's a diversity of voices
it's not just pro Trump propaganda I
still think it's a net positive it
shocks the trumpet's with an alternative
view
that they may not even know is out there
if they are only consuming FoxNews they
may never even hear about it in their
echo chamber so I think Shep and Chris
Wallace on Fox News are a net positive
even if they themselves often just toe
the party line let me know what you
think about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show we'll take a quick break and
be back with much more right after this
okay yesterday we went through the
content of Donald Trump's speech
declaring a national emergency to try to
get the border wall built and when we
talked about this yesterday I mentioned
to you that right after his Rose Garden
speech declaring this emergency and
talking about how this is all so
important and it's all got to be done
Donald Trump immediately went down to
one of his golf clubs and was spotted at
the omelet station and apparently I'm
not pronouncing omelet correctly and
we'll deal with that later on in the
show and he's pictured grabbing an
omelet before or after his golfing and
of course when you say I'm having an
emergency that's not usually followed by
I need a ham and cheese omelet and three
diet cokes immediately it's usually
followed by something related to the
emergency that you have declared right
the us-mexico border emergency which
requires commandeering funds
circumventing the will of Congress it's
even worse than we thought because now
we have found out that Donald Trump not
only golfed right after declaring the
national emergency he golfed three days
in a row three days in a row of a
national emergency so important that it
requires as far as Trump is concerned
circumventing the decisions made by the
US House and Senate and he couples them
with three days of golfing Saturday
reportedly included six hours of golf
interesting detail Trump has been
showing up to start golfing around 9:00
a.m. each of these three days Trump
doesn't even show up to the Oval Office
in the same building where he lives
until the level at 11:00 a.m. on a
normal day he has now made depending on
which numbers you look at between a
hundred and fifty nine and a hundred and
seventy two visits to Gaul
clubs during his presidency this is more
vacation than most people take in
multiple years who were not the
President of the United States and of
course Trump has also made money by
making these golf trips to his golf
clubs one example is that over the
weekend a Chinese delegation met with
Trump not at the White House but at his
mar-a-lago resort Trump is playing golf
and making money personally while a
national emergency
supposedly warrants getting around
Congress to commandeer money from the
military and the Department of Defense I
as I was reading about this it reminded
me of this infamous George W Bush moment
where he delivered an impactful
statement about terror right before
teeing off on the golf course we must
stop the terror I call upon all nations
to do everything they can to stop these
terrorist killers thank you now watch
this Drive there you go I don't actually
think Trump believes this is really an
emergency Pat I'm curious what you think
I believe Trump believes three million
Hillary voters voted illegally in 2016 I
believe that because he's privately it
continued to say it even after the
conversation was out of the media I
think Trump probably believes in real
life that the Russia probe is a
witch-hunt
I don't believe Trump actually thinks
there is a border crisis that warrants a
national emergency he even said during
the Rose Garden speech I didn't have to
do this I did this because I feel like
building the wall more quickly
I believe Pat that Trump knows deep down
this one is not real yeah I think he
just wants to rally and satisfy his face
of supporters and this vacation time to
me it sounds like he sees himself as
having completed the job like he worked
so hard to try to get wall funding
during the government shutdown to buckle
and then that three week period when we
didn't know if the government was going
to be shut down again that now he
deserves a vacation because he did what
had to do he declared the national
emergency and now we're moving on he can
take a break
whatever Trump thinks we've got to hope
that the courts are going to stop this
absolutely ridiculous power grab and
misuse of the national emergency
declaration either way under the
best-case scenario for the wall builders
not much of this wall is ever going to
be built even if Donald Trump has six
more years as president eight billion
dollars would in the best case scenario
build some tiny piece of the wall it
would take years lawsuits will slow it
down and the next Democratic president
will simply be able to end it so this
could change but unless something
radically changes even on the basis of
this declaration almost no wall is
actually going to be built and then that
transforms this from an actual
discussion about immigration policy and
what can be done pragmatically to just
political posturing about who can claim
victory on the wall as Pat pointed out
earlier and what that means is that
every American loses we all lose when
these become merely political footballs
that are thrown back and forth make sure
to follow me on instagram i'm on
instagram at david pakman also on the
david pakman show Instagram page we have
a very funny photo collage I I'm
actually calling it a photo essay from
producer Pat of producer max having
string cheese at david pakman show
studios and it was Max's birthday
earlier this week and to celebrate Max's
birthday on the at David Pakman show
Instagram account there's a photo essay
by producer Pat which I am just calling
Pat string cheese 2019 is how I would
like to describe it and shout out the
producer max I would say that he is on
the Mount Rushmore of current David
Pakman show producers yes and he's the
only person on that proverbial Mount
Rushmore interestingly enough all right
let's take a break we are going to talk
next about FOMO the fear of missing out
and it's going to be a really great
interview coming up in mere minutes
after this quick break as I told you
months ago he would be doing it Bernie
Sanders has announced he is running for
president he announced in exactly the
month February 20
nineteen that I was told by someone
close to Bernie in 2018 that he would be
doing it the part that hasn't worked out
as predicted is that when I was told
Bernie would be announcing in February
2019 the idea was that it would be one
of the first announcements and in fact
he is something like the I don't know
roughly tenth or twelfth Democratic
candidate to declare that he is seeking
the Democratic nomination in 2020 can we
say that bernie is now the front-runner
I don't know let's think it through
I mean the difference is from 2016 for
sure Bernie coming into the beginning of
the primary process with way more name
recognition I mean just exponentially
more than in 2016 he's known now within
the United States Senate or by the
United States of America as being the
farthest left senator within the United
States Senate that's a difference from
2016 and there's also this big
contingent that believes Bernie Sanders
would have defeated Trump in 2016 had he
been the nominee rather than Hillary
Clinton so that all is in favor of
Bernie now being the de facto
frontrunner on the other side of this is
a contingent and I don't know how big it
is I'm trying to assess how big it is
that's quite frankly furious with Bernie
Sanders because they some believe cost
Hillary Clinton the presidency in 2016 I
don't believe that but there's a
contingent that does believe that all
sorts of progressives on my Facebook
page saying they don't know who they're
voting for
but they're definitely not voting for
Bernie some mentioning this thing about
they are Democrats and Bernie isn't so
that is is the reason some are citing
that they will not be supporting Bernie
Sanders in 2020 my message to people who
are really angry with Bernie is that
medicare-for-all being talked about as
much as it's being talked about today by
the Democratic candidates is because of
Bernie Sanders tuition free college
being discussed today
in the way that it is is because of
Bernie Sanders in 2016
people like Alexandria Acacio Cortez and
that contingent in Congress today is
significantly a Bernie Sanders is
significantly responsible for that
movement which led to the election of
many of those candidates the idea of not
taking PAC money something we can
connect to Bernie Sanders so for me
right now it's not really that important
whether he is the front-runner or not he
certainly no longer the underdog as he
may have been considered in 2016 he is
without a doubt a top contender Cory
Booker Peter Budaj edge Julian Castro
John Delaney Tulsi Kirsten Gillibrand
Klobuchar Andrew yang Bernie is
certainly immediately ahead of them I
would put him along with Elizabeth
Warren and Kamala Harris probably as the
frontrunner right now but I don't even
think that's really the important
conversation to be having at this point
in time because frontrunners in February
of the year before the election don't
typically end up being the nominees now
typically kind of goes out the window
Donald Trump is President of the United
States but think back to Richard
Gephardt or John Edwards so I don't
think it's particularly useful to say
who's the front-runner right now what we
can do is look at data on his first day
in only the first four hours raising
money today Bernie Sanders has already
matched the campaign donations that
Kamala Harris received in her entire
first day after announcing in just four
hours so there's no question here that
Bernie Sanders very quickly is towards
the front I think that the the real
questions are going to be has Bernie
Sanders done damage to himself by virtue
of being so successful in 2016 and what
I mean by that is in 2016
Bernie talking about Medicare for all
tuition free college a higher marginal
tax rates on the rich he was an outlier
in discussing
that now that those ideas thanks to
Bernie have been so much further
mainstreamed he no longer stands out as
the only candidate who supports those
things now of course with Medicare for
all there is a difference between the
Bernie Sanders position which is
Medicare for all as the way and here's
how we would pay for it and here's a
bill I've already introduced to do it
versus more moderate centrist Democrats
who are sort of playing coy and saying
sure Medicare for all would be nice but
I just don't think it's going to happen
and here's some tweaks we can make to
Obamacare so we have Bernie to thank for
a lot of that conversation I think that
it may well become an issue that Bernie
Sanders is not a democrat but caucuses
with Democrats in the Senate that's
something I'm already seeing a lot of
discussion of on social media I think
that much like with Elizabeth Warren's
DNA test fiasco I think that Bernie
Sanders and allegations of sexism not by
him but within the ranks of a 2016
campaign is probably going to be made an
issue by some of his opponents and my
advice right now would be let's continue
assessing the candidates on their
platforms let's start to think about
what their candidacies would look like
up against Donald Trump I think it's
okay to start considering that at this
point and don't try to reason with
people who are super Pro aoc but are
saying they hate Bernie because they
were born out of the same movement and I
think that that is how the left will
destroy itself we don't want to fall
victims to the narcissism of small
differences and that's a phenomena that
I'm going to be talking about a little
bit later on in the program and maybe on
a live stream this evening as well so
we'll continue following the early
candidacy of Bernie Sanders not a
surprise that he announced more
surprising that he is only like the
tenth or twelfth candidate to make the
announcement I told you yesterday that
the world is both laughing at and
ignoring Donald Trump and one reason is
that geopolitically it's increasingly
clear that he is compromised not just by
but also apparently at least in some
ways to some degree by Saudi Arabia and
the Russia piece we've talked a lot
about and I'm guessing you're a regular
viewer or listener of this program you
know a lot about that piece the South
the Saudi Arabia portion of it maybe you
know less about and that is very very
quickly changing because yesterday we
learned that multiple whistle whistle
blowers have come forward with
allegations that if true could be the
biggest scandal of the Trump
administration so far and that really
says a lot in an administration that has
been scandal-plagued on really an almost
weekly basis we're now talking no longer
about just leaking we're talking about
whistleblowing about issues of grave
national security concern because
whistleblowers went to the House
Oversight and Reform Committee claiming
that the Trump White House is
transferring sensitive American nuclear
technology to Saudi Arabia this would
potentially be illegal because it would
violate the Atomic Energy Act which says
that any transfer of information to a
foreign country of data that could be
used to create nuclear weapons must be
reviewed and approved by Congress
obviously that didn't happen and it's
clear here that the claims from the
whistleblowers if true imply the
commission of federal crimes
whistleblowers say that within the White
House ethics advisors have been telling
the Trump administration you've got to
stop this you can't do this and the
Trump administration is ignoring it the
whistleblowers aren't making vague
amorphous claims they have presented to
the House committee very specific
information including the names of
people and the dates on which those
people did things related to these
transfers of technology to Saudi Arabia
they are naming specific corporations
involved including one called
IP three international and now that
we've heard these allegations we
start to put together that this is not
an unrelated sort of compartmentalised
story that doesn't coincide with so much
else of what we've learned over the last
two years this connects to so many other
allegations that fit very neatly into an
increasingly clear big picture I'll give
you some examples we've been talking for
a while now about golden boy Jared
Kushner's visits to Saudi Arabia and
contacts with Saudi Arabia that may be
involved here in a quid pro quo
- which Kushner is connected we've
talked about the Trump administration
being very soft handed with Saudi Arabia
about the killing of journalists
Jamal Shoji this connects to Michael
Flynn Michael Flynn Donald Trump's now
convicted national security advisor was
an advisor to this corporation ip3
international while he was Donald
Trump's national security adviser and he
has previously unreported trips to Saudi
Arabia and lastly Pat this is urgent
this is not a this is what happened 18
months ago story this reportedly is
taking place as recently as last week
this is going on the only question for
me Pat is was this in exchange for
political favors was this in exchange
for money is someone getting rich off of
these transfers and how many crimes may
have been committed and of course with
Trump there's always a layer of
hypocrisy so remember he adds a pull out
of the Iran deal because there's no way
they could possibly have nuclear
capabilities they're an Islamic
government they're monarchy they're
corrupt they're hostile towards their
own people and they're hostile towards
the West so absolutely Iran cannot have
nuclear weapons Saudi Arabia you can say
the exact same things right the same
exact criticisms and yet he's willing to
give them nuclear capabilities come on
and the the hypocrisy is also
particularly noticeable because of the
entire fake conspiracy about Hillary
Clinton's uranium one which alleged a
quid pro quo regarding nuclear materials
but was actually totally bogus this is a
story where we have real evidence and
a reportedly specific quid pro quo in
which Jared Kushner might be involved
Donald Trump's son-in-law an advisor and
fortunately House Democrats are already
looking at broader foreign influence on
Donald Trump that goes beyond Russia and
it's almost getting to the point where
we may need another special prosecutor
simply focused on what's going on with
Saudi Arabia I told you Monday
the real national emergency is not at
the us-mexico border it's in the Oval
Office and here is yet another example
of that just absolutely stunning what we
are learning every single week